- [Narrator] This is like
a giant vacuum cleaner
for the atmosphere,
and it could be one answer
to slashing Earth's carbon emissions.
- We take it out of the air
so we reverse climate change.
- [Narrator] This is
same as cleaning up some
of the 33 billion tons of carbon dioxide
that humans will release
into the atmosphere
by the end of the year.
And the International Energy Agency
says it's the highest concentration ever.
- [Crowd] Save our planet.
- [Narrator] Companies are
increasingly facing pressure
from consumers and investors
to reduce their carbon footprints.
So some are turning to the
carbon capture industry
that's forecasted to be worth
approximately $15 billion by 2027.
Microsoft and Audi are
investing in this technology,
while Coca-Cola is purchasing
the carbon that's caught.
- We believe it's one of the solutions
to fight climate change.
- [Narrator] But some
climate experts doubt
the technology can have
a meaningful impact
on the environment.
- Probably one of the
biggest challenges here
is having captured it,
what can you do with it?
- [Narrator] We visit one of the largest
open air carbon capture
facilities on the planet
to see how it absorbs, then sells its CO2,
and how that could help
companies become cleaner.
A lot of companies are trying
to remove carbon dioxide from the air.
Some want to capture it directly
by attaching filters
on trucks and factories
or by installing ventilation
systems in leading rooms.
- Here we basically have air being pumped
inside this chamber.
- [Narrator] But Climeworks
takes carbon dioxide
directly out of the atmosphere.
- We blow air through this
collector using a ventilator.
The CO2 sticks inside this box,
and stays there.
- [Narrator] Nathalie Casas
leads Climeworks' research program.
She says this facility
is made up of 30 ventilators
that can pull in about 1,500 tons
of carbon dioxide out of
the atmosphere every year.
- Inside the collector,
we have a filter material.
This filter material is able to catch CO2.
(dramatic music)
- [Narrator] Casas says
the biggest challenge
is making it affordable to set up and use.
Building and installing just
one of these ventilators here
at this facility costs
as much as $220,000.
And it also needs a lot of electricity.
So to clean up the amount of CO2 someone
in the US would typically
produce in about a month,
that's everything from commuting to work
to consuming food and watching TV,
the company says it would
cost around anywhere
from 600 to nearly $900.
- The target, of course,
is to bring costs down,
to bring the energy requirements down,
and to make it easily scalable.
- [Narrator] So Casas has been working
on designing larger plants
that would use renewable energy sources
and require less steel.
But one of the most promising ways
to offset the cost has
been tapping directly
into the captured CO2.
Climeworks stores the
carbon dioxide it collects
into these tanks.
Then it sells it to this Coca-Cola factory
that produces bottled water.
Here, recycled carbon dioxide
is injected in the water to make it fizzy.
- 30% of our production is done
with the recycled CO2 from Climeworks.
- [Narrator] Patrick Wittweiler oversees
the carbon dioxide project at Coca-Cola.
He says early on, there were challenges,
like turning the carbon dioxide
into the right kind of liquified form.
- We run a lot of tests and validations
just to be sure that the quality remains
on the highest level.
- [Narrator] Wittweiler
says using recycled CO2
is significantly more expensive
than the commercial kind.
But Coca-Cola is committed to lowering
its environmental footprint.
Over time, he expects
the costs to diminish
and that would allow the
company to expand the use
of recycled CO2 from bottled water
to other drinks like Coke.
- We're testing it,
and we look into further expansions.
- [Narrator] Making drinks fizzy
is just one way to use recycled CO2.
Carbon capture startups
have also been experimenting
with creating fuel,
toothpaste and plastic.
Climeworks also has another way to profit
from the carbon it captures.
The startup sells what it
calls a carbon removal service
so that individuals or
companies like Shopify and Audi
can offset their own emissions.
- You are flying to Mallorca,
but I know it's not so
good for the environment.
I really wanna compensate,
you can buy carbon dioxide.
- [Narrator] This part of the industry
is booming and fast evolving
as regulators and climate analysts debate
how to best price this type of service.
- There are better ways
of capturing the carbon
dioxide than they're using.
- [Narrator] Sandra Kentish is a professor
at the University of Melbourne
who tracks and compares
carbon capture systems
around the world.
She says it's harder to absorb CO2
from the atmosphere,
rather than a direct source of pollution.
- The CO2 concentration in the atmosphere
is only about .04%.
Cement production, as an example,
CO2 concentration's around 30%.
So it's hundreds of times easier
to capture from something
like a cement flue gas
than it will be directly
from the atmosphere.
(dramatic music)
- [Narrator] This inefficiency means
that to capture 1% of
the world's emissions
in a year, Climeworks would have to build
around 800,000 ventilators.
But Casas says the company's technology
can still make a difference.
- Unfortunately, the mass is already here.
So we need to take out CO2.
- [Narrator] And Climeworks
plans to take out more CO2
with a near facility in Iceland
that was built with some
funding from Microsoft.
When it opens in September,
the company says the plant will be able
to absorb about four times more
than its Swiss facility.
But this time, the carbon
dioxide won't be recycled.
It'll be injected in the ground
and turned into a rock.
- These are these white crystals.
So this CO2 is actual
CO2, which was in the air.
- [Narrator] And this kind of evolution
is how Climeworks hopes its technology
will become cheaper so
that it can clean the air
for companies searching for new ways
to reduce their own emissions.
(dramatic music)